hi everyone oh let me change one thing
that's better now I look more
symmetrical if you were to draw a line
down my Center I'd have a symmetry
around that line
not exactly but it's as close as I can
get symmetry is actually an advanced
mathematical idea and it's something
that I enjoyed learning about while
studying mathematics
I studied symmetries through a course on
group theory which takes all the
symmetries and object has and treats
them together as a group of operations a
critical test for symmetry is that
something looks the same even if you
change the way you're looking at it for
example I can look at this seed code in
five different ways and it looks the
same this object has a cyclic group of
symmetries of order five and it's not
just visual patterns that can be studied
group Theory also applies to looking for
sameness when taking measurements and
different ways this is an example I have
done before on this table but it's
relevant again now if I rotate my arm
once there is not symmetry but if I
rotate it twice I'm back where I started
this demo represents a group that has
symmetry under two rotations in fact
from the mental symmetry principles
dictate the basic laws of physics and
chemistry which is why I find it so
interesting
another interesting myth of course I
took as part of my degree looked at
mathematical paradoxes one in particular
that I remember was Russell's
[ __ ] now to understand this you'll have
to know a little bit about sets that's
kind of easy a set is just a group of
things for example me and you would be
part of the set of people unless you're
a cat
so Russell's paradox asks you to form
the set of all sets that don't contain
themselves and asks does the set contain
itself gets kind of complicated it's
best to sort of write it down and think
about this but it can be illustrated in
the barbershop problem so if you have a
barber who shaves everyone in town
except people that shave themselves who
shaves the barber if you think about it
well if the barber tried to shave
himself there'd be a problem because the
barber doesn't shave people who shave
himself and if you got someone else to
shave the barber
then that wouldn't work either because
the barber shades everyone who doesn't
shave himself you get kind of into a
lupine and that's why it's a paradox it
represents that there are sometimes
problems with how we think about maths
of the most fundamental level because
creating sets to hold numbers and ideas
is something that happens pretty often
when writing mathematics paradoxes like
this help to form the direction of
mathematical rules and philosophy going
forwards I found it pretty interesting
to study because it was a chance to
really look and think about what
mathematics is rather than treating it
as purely a tool to do other things
lastly I want to really quickly mention
linear algebra this is a topic where you
can take
bunch of equations you have take the
coefficients and put them into a matrix
pretty much you can reduce any system of
equation down to the form ax equals B
where a is your matrix X is like the
vector of things you're trying to solve
for and B is the vector of solutions now
I'm not going to go into how to solve
these problems that includes
manipulating the matrices but it
actually turns out to be pretty cool and
makes computing systems of equations a
lot easier in some cases say for example
you have three equations representing
three claims in 3d space by looking at
the matrix you can find out if there be
no solutions to your problem so these
three planes never intersect you can
find out if they'll be one solution so
they will intersect in one place or if
there will be infinitely many solutions
and that's pretty cool to be able to
find out thanks for watching this was a
requested follow-up video to one I did
about three things I actually learned
during a physics degree if you have any
questions or want to discuss any of the
ideas here please leave a comment below